Hello, hello, Halloween!
One more time.
BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Midnight!
FUWAMOCO Midnight hajimaru yo!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
And today we're your spooky hosts of FUWAMOCO Midnight, the Halloween special!
Thank you for joining us, Ruffians, for such a spooky, spooky time of the year!
BAU BAU!
For any Ruffians joining us for the first time today, FUWAMOCO Midnight is a short format morning show held this Halloween week.
And it's hosted by us!
FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to send shivers down your spine and help you start your day off with some Halloween spirit!
And maybe some candy.
Maybe, maybe.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag.
Hashtag FWMCMIDNIGHT.
Midnight.
Let's all say BAU BAU to a very spooky FUWAMOCO Midnight!
BAU!
It doesn't have the same ring as BAU BAU.
I only see a few BAU BAUs.
BAU BAU.
Ruffians!
It sounds like we're all crying a bit.
BAU BAU is better.
We can all agree on that.
BAU BAU.
You know, Halloween's so close, but... but... was... Did anybody see Pero?
It's kind of hard, maybe he blended in with all the ghosts at this time of year.
When Ruffians saw, was he... de-den!
Spooky!
Wait, so Pero came by and threatened you so then he could get some candy?
It's a good thing he wasn't too brave and ran off when you told him to scram, you know?
You must be a very rough and tough looking Ruffian!
Make him listen!
Either that or your costume scared him off maybe?
Maybe.
But I think this is a very creative way of remembering that encounter.
Yeah, it's important to make physical evidence of the crime.
Crime?
The crime committed!
Well, there was no crime, but it doesn't matter.
It was scary.
It was spooky.
You felt unwell, right?
Unwell.
But that aside, that's a very beautiful pumpkin.
Maybe the whole idea also gave you some well-deserved pumpkin inspiration.
I don't know, I think... I really like this pumpkin.
It looks sort of soft.
It looks sort of fuzzy.
Right!
I think, you know, this pumpkin is the perfect pumpkin for the job, for your carving.
Good canvas.
Right?
It looks very happy.
I know you can see all the effort and sweat and blood that you put into it too.
Spooky.
Watch out, Peron!
It rhymes with being overlooked, okay?
BAU BAU for the beautiful pumpkin!
Speaking of boo... Speaking of boo... We have another.
A bee boo.
Ruffians!
There's already been some Halloween tweets given out, but...
You didn't miss it, right?
You didn't miss out on it, right?
Well, Advent Sparkling Gem!
Koseki Bijou just released our second cover song!
Brand new song cover!
I love it!
It's super spooky and... Can you guess what love is?
We absolutely love it!
We love it!
We love it, love it.
You know, you can really see how hard Bijou worked on it.
And through this song, you can really see a different side of her that's really cool and sort of cute, sort of creepy.
Sort of cute.
A bit scary.
I feel like with both songs, Biboo makes them her own.
Right?
But this is a totally different Biboo that we haven't seen.
I see some Ruffians thinking weird things.
I don't know, it's kind of... In one way, intoxicating, no?
Why silence?
What a Ruffian!
Are you scared?
Please, please absolutely check out Biboo's new cover!
She rocked it.
Rock, rock, rock, rock.
Ruffians.
We heard from you recently that there's something that's been sending some shivers down your spine.
Do you know what that is?
There's a lot of things, but this in particular.
The concept of
BAU time.
Even us, FUWAMOCO, we've been feeling it too.
Yeah!
Yeah.
Have you felt, you know, the past three months since we debuted, time has gone like super duper duper fast, right?
But it also kind of feels like it's been like a really long time at the same time, like fast and long.
I don't know how it works like that, but, you know, I feel like we've been feeling BAU time extremely much.
And it's sort of frightening.
Just sort of frightening.
It's been so much fun together.
So it's kind of like we lost track of time, but then also not at all.
It's weird.
It's a weird state to be in, Ruffians.
Yeah, the concept of BAU time, I think it's very complex.
And because it's so complex, it's really frightening.
It's terrifying!
Right?
It's been three months!
Yeah, your BAU time, too.
Yesterday was yesterday, yo.
It was, but what was yesterday?
When did today start?
When did yesterday end?
Exactly.
It's frightening.
Yeah.
But, you know, for FUWAMOCO, there are a lot of things that we're afraid of, but... You say that like it's something to be proud of.
It's a fact.
No denying.
But right now, I think BAU time is what we're scared of the most.
It's not a time loop, it's just...
It's like... It's fast, but that's the sound of it going by.
I don't know.
It's like long but short.
I know.
I don't know.
But maybe time will go back to normal soon?
Maybe.
The fun times together will absolutely continue, but hopefully time returns sort of back to normal, back to how it was.
Do you think you will, Ruffians?
It goes like that, like really fast.
You know the car.
Not a cat.
Are you sure that's not a Minecraft cat?
No.
Imagine the race car.
It goes... Like that.
Yeah, but that's a fast car.
Yes!
It goes fast.
But it also goes, like, slow?
I don't know, it's like... It's fast and thick.
I don't know.
That's BAU time.
Yeah.
Be scared, okay, Ruffians?
Spooky things be happening.
Spooky.
But... I think Moco-chan, you might have a confession to make just in time for Halloween.
I might.
Ruffians, it's a little scary.
Do you think that you're ready to hear it?
Is your heart ready?
If you're holding any drinks, maybe you should put them down before you drop them or swallow the candy.
No choking, okay?
Are you ready?
Maybe it's pretty scary.
Well, ready or not, here I speak.
So,
Maybe you noticed it.
Maybe some of the sharp Ruffians sharp.
But maybe some other ones haven't.
That's okay.
Have you noticed the spectacular shape of my mouth?
You see, it's sort of round, but then it has two sort of ear shapes to it.
The ear shapes are Moco-chan's teeth.
You see?
Like that.
I see.
But, there's actually a reason for it.
It's cute.
There's a reason, okay?
It's not just cute.
I know.
It's because... It's the perfect size to fit... A KITTEN HEAD!
See?
It looks like a kitten's head.
It really does.
And you know what they say.
If a cat can fit its head through a hole, then it can fit its whole body through too, right?
That's what they say.
It's the same as my mouth!
It's perfect.
You get it, right, Ruffians?
Just kidding!
You know, when we talk about eating kittens, I don't mean it like that.
No.
I just like to rub my face all over them and then kiss them lots and then huff their tummies and whatnot.
That's all.
It's practically eating them, you know?
Right!
Right.
Sure.
You have to believe me to get the treat.
The treat.
Moco-chan's treat.
Cats are friends, but why can't you eat them too?
Well, I'm sure you never thought anything sinister, right?
We love cats.
Just wanna kiss and smell them.
That's all.
Right?
Right.
That's kinda scary.
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
There's something that I've been wondering.
Have you remembered yet?
Have you?
There's a very special day coming up that you better remember.
We talked about it.
Yeah.
You better remember it.
I know.
It's been over a week since we mentioned it last, right?
You definitely know by now, right?
There's no way you wouldn't know.
You thought about it, right?
Right?
Very soon.
It's really important to us.
We set it up soon.
It's really, really important.
Hello, fans.
You know what's important to us.
What's important to FUWAMOCO.
I thought the Ruffians knew, but... I don't know.
Well, that's...
More important than the cover song to FUWAMOCO.
Well, we were asked if anyone figured it out yet.
Yeah.
And we saw one Ruffian guess it.
One.
One singular Ruffian.
Yeah.
But I don't think they even realized it then.
Nope.
Isn't that a bit scary?
Maybe a bit spooky?
Doesn't it make your hair stand on end a little bit?
BAU!
You better think of it!
If the Ruffians don't remember soon... Moco-chan... How should we punish them?
We'll have to think of that.
We'll think of that while you think.
Think hard, okay?
We might have to play a trick on you pretty soon, but first... Do they deserve it though?
I don't know.
But first we'll give you a treat!
Do they deserve it though?
Today at 5pm PT, 9am JST, we have our second cover song premiering on YouTube!
We're super excited for you to listen to it!
You know, we'll also be having an afterparty after the song premiere.
So we hope that you'll come and join us and share your thoughts with us about it there too.
You know, but... I think, I think... I think you know that we haven't shared what song it is with you yet.
Did you realize?
Did you wanna find out?
No, not yet.
You don't wanna know yet.
Well, maybe the Ruffians... Maybe we should make them act like ghosts.
And say BAU BAU for us if you wanna find out.
Can you BAU BAU for me?
BAU!
Not moo.
FUWAMOCO-chan!
I guess.
Our second cover song is... De-den!
Cute na Kanojo!
BAU BAU!
It's a song originally by Shudo, but very cute and very creepy.
We hope you enjoy FUWAMOCO version very soon.
You know, cause we're always watching, right?
You know?
BAU BAU!
I'm excited.
Ruffians, we look forward to it!
Well, you know, since Halloween is only a day away, we thought that we'd share one of our earliest Halloween memories with you.
You know, as you might remember from I think it was our
Collab with Calli-senpai, right?
But Halloween is one of our favorite holidays, even though we don't like scary things.
And it's been like that forever!
You know, they celebrate very similarly in the Northwest Passage too.
Yeah, as the humans, you know?
So, well... Back when we were just tiny puppers, Mama Puppy and Papa Puppy, they decided to take us to see some fireworks.
And...
After we did some trick-or-treating, we went and did that, you know?
We were tired, so... But we were told that we could only eat one candy out of all the trick-or-treating candies we had gathered!
So we picked them and took them with us, you know?
Yeah, ate the one.
Yeah.
But when we got to the fireworks...
Of course, we're still really little.
Just little puppers, right?
So Mama Puppy and Papa Puppy, they picked us up and put us on their shoulders so that we could see the fireworks a little bit better.
And then what happened, Fuwawa?
Well, Ruffians, you know, when the fireworks exploded to the sky, they're really beautiful, right?
What do you do when that happens, you know?
The fireworks go BABAM BABAO.
And then you go... BAAAAAAA!
Right?
Right.
Right!
In the Northwest Passage it goes BAAA!
And fireworks are at Halloween.
Yeah, right.
But, uh, well... Nobody had really realized that what I chose as my candy was bubble gum.
And of course you know the fireworks being so amazing and everything!
It might have just made me lose my gum that I was chewing!
And I dropped it right into Mama Puppy's hair.
Yeah.
She was very surprised.
Very very surprised.
Yeah, I... I still kinda feel bad for her.
I don't think she's forgotten.
No!
But you know, sometimes fireworks are just too pretty!
Yeah, you can't help it, right?
It's an easy mistake no matter how old you are, you know?
I'm sure, right.
Although I don't think the same thing would happen if you're... ...older, right?
Mochomoco-chan.
And that's a story.
Ruffians, have you had a similar experience before?
Did she get her fur shaved?
Well, you know, Mama Puppy's pretty fluffy, pretty fuzzy, so it wasn't easy.
It wasn't good.
Yeah, it wasn't good.
But thinking about Mama Puppy, guys!
Yeah.
Mama Puppy's not the Doggie of the Day.
No.
But it's Doggie of the Day!
We have!
Wait.
Today's Doggie of the Night.
Doggie of the Night.
Oh, whoops.
Doggie of the Night!
What do you mean whoops, Moco-chan?
Whoops.
Today's Doggie of the Night is... B-Man!
BAU BAU BAU BAU!
B-Man!
B-Man.
Yeah.
Do we have a wedding coming with B-Man?
I guess he's not too good with scary things, huh?
No, no.
I don't know what to do with the zombie head.
B-Man's kind of frozen.
But regardless of bone or gristle, us dogs won't and don't chew on anything and everything, you know?
Don't you imagine us doing those things like that either, okay?
And I don't know if B-Man does that, but certainly not us, okay?
Manners.
You made the zombie head yourself!
Why?
That's... Why?
Horrifying animation.
You don't... Do you need that?
A zombie head?
I guess to celebrate Halloween, right?
I don't know.
You could just have a happy looking pumpkin, right?
I guess.
Well, how does B-Man BAU BAU?
If B-Man saw a zombie coming towards them, what would they sound like?
Really?
BAU!
That was a bit scary there, but wouldn't it sound more like something a bit more alarming, like BAU!
It could be both. Well, you know, I think B-Man doesn't think they're that ready for Halloween yet. And I think we feel the same too despite, you know, having all that training that we got this month. We did our best, though.
BAU
I think we can tell that they still love you regardless.
Good for it for B-Man.
But I think B-Man might like to request that you make something not so scary.
Maybe preferably something that they could kind of take a bite and chew on comfortably.
Chew.
It's good.
BAU BAU!
Happy Halloween together!
We're at Walk of the Night.
Walk of the Night.
Is that a walk?
A scary night out?
You went to Dracula's castle?
Did you go inside of it?
With your bag?
Mommy.
I don't know.
We actually... For some reason, we don't know much about Dracula because vampires are scary.
They're scary.
Yeah.
And, you know, they're local, so... You say that you're not a vampire, but... I don't know.
Ruffians do... Do vampires tell stories to try and trick you?
Are they those kind of... Those kind of scary ones?
Yeah.
Are they?
I don't know.
Can we trust you?
Maybe... Maybe we should do... I don't know.
I don't know.
We'll see it now!
No touching the fluff!
No touching the fuzz!
And a new one!
No biting either the fuzz!
Got it.
Yeah.
It's new.
You have to remember, no biting.
No biting.
Yeah.
Proper manners.
BAU BAU!
And for our question of the night, we have De-den!
It says night.
Night.
Hello FUWAMOCO!
Hello!
I have a question.
We see BAU BAU and BAU BAU.
Are there any more types of BAU BAU?
For example, BAU BAU or BAU BAU?
If there are, what do they mean?
Well, I think BAU BAU and BAU BAU.
Yeah.
This wouldn't make sense, right?
Those are like the universal BAU BAUs, right?
It's like... BAU BAU!
Yeah.
And...
BAU BAU!
But there is BAU BAU.
It's just BAU BAU.
I got it.
I think it's a bit more difficult for humans to understand, right?
And then BAU BAU?
It's a bit impolite.
BAU BAU?
So it's like you're giving a bit of a sass.
Yeah.
BAU BAU is like a bit more awkward.
I take that back.
You can go, I'm not.
Yeah, it's like, oh I feel...
I feel funny.
Yeah.
That kind of BAU BAU.
Again, this one's kind of hard for humans to understand that well too, so... You wouldn't get it that easily.
Yeah.
So BAU BAU!
And BAU BAU... BAU BAU is probably the easiest.
Yeah.
Got it!
Understood!
Does that make sense, Ruffians?
You understand the differences in why we only go BAU BAU!
BAU BAU!
BAU BAU, right?
Makes sense.
Right, right.
I'm happy that it makes sense.
I feel like we got closer.
Who was that?
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for your submissions, you know?
FUWAMOCO Midnight is something that, you know, we make together.
Just like FUWAMOCO Morning.
Just this once a year.
Even if midnight maybe becomes morning, we're still always looking for more doggy of the
Cute girlfriend after party!
We're having our
Afterparty for cute no kanojo, so we hope that after you come to the premiere, which you'll definitely be at, right?
Right!
Pretty much right after that ends, we'll be having an afterparty for it.
And you know we're gonna talk about, you know, just what it means to us, and, uh, you know, what our feelings were when we were recording it and everything, so we hope that you'll be there.
Maybe that you can let us know your thoughts, too!
Well, Ruffians.
You'll be there, right?
I'll be there!
You'll be there!
Definitely!
Can't wait for it!
We'll be waiting.
Come on!
Okay!
Next, our schedule!
Our schedule.
We have to continue thinking.
We have!
Well, today is a busy day, but tomorrow is Halloween.
And, you know, we have a lot of fun that we're going to be having together.
First, we're going to be playing a spooky Halloween TTRPG for the first time ever, together with Calli-senpai as the Game Master, as well as Ina-senpai, and Bae-senpai, Kronii-senpai too.
We're looking forward to it but kind of nervous too.
It's our first TT RPG ever.
Yeah, extra spooky.
And after that we're having a big Halloween costume party together with all of our friends.
But it doesn't end there.
It doesn't, it doesn't.
Finally we'll be ending off the Halloween fun with a spooky story time where we'll be reading out your scary stories, Ruffians.
BAU BAU!
Are you ready?
Are you ready for it?
BAU BAU!
This week, my baby!
So ready!
We're ready too.
Are we?
I'm ready.
I don't know Moco-chan is.
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for joining us today for our spooky FUWAMOCO Midnight!
Did we scare you?
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our extra spooky Ruffians today!
Extra spooky Ruffians!
Stay tuned!
BAU BAU!
Aselia!
Gengar!
BAU BAU!
Jellypaw!
Race!
BAU BAU!
Ironclad!
Twitch!
BAU BAU!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl, howl, howloween!
Howl, howl, howloween!
Have a day.
And night.
This was FUWAMOCO Midnight!